[Musique]
la journée internationale du 28
septembre pour le droit à l'avortement
c'est une journée qui existe depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années et qui
effectivement regroupe tous les pays
que soit d'un des pays où la loi
légalisent l'avortement ou bien des pays
où c'est interdit
[Musique]
ce droit politiquement intervient dans
beaucoup d'élections quand on prend une
position antichois en général c'est anti
choix global c'est-à-dire anti choix
avortement mais également restriction
contraceptive en Pologne la
contraception d'urgence par exemple est
difficile
ça va également sur comment concevoir la
famille
en gris pour le moment c'est très
hétérosexuel et très traditionnel donc
c'est vraiment la place des femmes dans
la société qui est remise en question et
là c'est parti donc pour la
[Musique]
voilà tranquillement
alors ce livre j'ai eu envie de l'écrire
d'abord c'était d'abord c'était un
exercice purement personnel j'avais
besoin d'écrire moi sur d'un point de
vue intime sur les deux avortements que
j'avais vécu je suis la preuve qu'un
avortement peut provoquer l'indifférence
ou une déflagration
je suis la preuve quand même corps peut
vivre deux fois ce même événement en
mobilisant de façon totalement
différente la tête qui le surplombe ou
les émotions qu'il a mis
alors j'ai été là en toi fermé ou
moralisateur de ceux qui n'en savent
rien j'ai été là c'est j'ai eu envie de
laisser la parole à celle qui est l'ont
vécu et que l'on écoute pas faudra
toujours se battre parce qu'il y a de
toute façon des oppositions idéologiques
droit à l'avortement et puis la liberté
des femmes à disposer de leur corps
c'est quand même l'arme absolue pour
maîtriser les femmes et pour empêcher
l'égalité et la liberté des femmes
[Musique]
quand on manifeste le soir on pense aux
Américains on pense au polonaise on
pense hongroise oui c'est un combat où
on sent effectivement qu'on est tous
rassemblé c'est un moment où on pense
pas aux Françaises on pense à toutes les
femmes et quand on sait qu'il y a une
femme qui meurt toutes les 9 minutes
dans le monde d'un avortement clandestin
on pensait tout seul là
[Musique]
ça va
la situation internationale nous alerte
à lowers parce que malheureusement on
constate que
des pays comme les États-Unis des pays
dit développer régresse donc on prend on
ne peut pas se dire imperméable à ce
mouvement
anti choix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec les États-Unis quand on voit
comment ça escalader
la loi reversé
[Musique]
c'est une grande influence
il y a du monde c'est vivant c'est non
c'est bien c'est bien on est on est
vraiment contente
[Musique]